اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الفقره للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
معنا دائما المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري اهلا بك قبل ان نتحدث مع اللواء
فايز الدويري نذهب للزميل محمود الكن واخر
التحديثات فيما يتعلق بما جرى في ظل هذا
اليوم من ايام الهدنه نعم عبد السلام الان
نحن نتحدث عن وجود عمليات خلال هذه الفتره
ربما عمليات على المستوى التكتيكي لا تؤدي
الى انهيار الهدنه لكنها كانت لا فته هنا
كتائب القسام كانت قد اعلنت بانها في شمال
قطاع غزه هذا هو الشمال هذا هو جنوب بديده
غزه كان تم تفعيل ثلاث عبوات ناسفه وادت
الى اصابه على الاقل في واحده منها بين
الجنود هذا يعني امرين اولا كنا نتحدث
سابقا عن التوغل دوما وليس سيطره استخدام
العبوات الناسفه يعني اقتراب القوات من
مسافه قريبه عشرات الامتار ربما لتفعيل
هذه العبوات الناسفه التي اما تكون ملتصقه
او يتم تفعيلها عبر اسلاك شحنه كهربائيه ع
عبر اسلاك او عن بعد
بالتالي لكن المدى يجب ان يكون قريبا
بالتالي هذه ما تزال عمليه لافته في هذا
الاتجاه وتعيد توازنا تكتيكيا بانه لا يجب
ان يتم استهداف او عمل اي خروقات خلال
فتره الهدنه اللافت ايضا ما حدث هنا في
عمليه تبادل المحتجزين الان بالنسبه
للمحتجزين كانوا قد مروا عبر ا معبر رفح
لكن ايضا لوحظ انه تم التسليم من فصيلين
ال حماس والجهاد الاسلامي وهذا ما يثير
عمليه التساؤلات حول تعقيد عمليه عمليه
عسكريه تسمى
بتحرير المختطف مفين او الرهائن
بالتالي حسب الروايه الاسرائيليه هذا
النوع هناك تشكيك من الخبراء حول امكانيه
تحقيق عسكريا هذا الهدف في ظل
تعقيد التوزع الجغرافي المجموعات المشاركه
الى اخره وهذا ما سنقوم
بتحليله معكما عبد السلام وسياده اللواء
فايز الدويري اضافه الى الاصابات التي
عانى منها الجيش الاسرائيلي ومنها اخر ما
حدث اليوم نعم واعلن هو بطبيعه الحال عن
بعض خسائره فيما يتعلق بالجرحى وان كان لا
يوجد هناك ارقام فيما يتعلق بالعدد
النهائي للقتلى شكرا لك محمود سياده
اللواء استمعت الى هذا الحديث قبل ان
نتحدث عن الخروقات ومدى تاثيرها لم يكن
هناك اثر كبير اليوم تمت عمليه يعني تتم
الان عمليه التبادل بشكل اعتيادي كما
تابعنا في الايام السابقه فالخروج لم يكن
لها اي اي اثر واضح لكن السؤال هنا عن
المعطى الجديد هو ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
بدا يفصح عن تفاصيل اكثر فيما يتعلق
بخسائر في حربه على قطاع غزه اعتقد هذا
جاء ضغط من قبل صحيفه ارتس وبالتالي انها
هددت باللجوء الى المحكمه لماذا لانه
لديها معلومات قالت انها ستكشف وكانت هناك
تصريحات مضاده طالبت حتى لمستوى اغلاق
الصحيفه ولكن عندما هددت باللجوء الى
المحكمه العليا تم الافراج عن جزء من هذا
من هذا الخسائر لا اعتقد ان الرقم 2000 هو
رقم ثابت او الرقم 395 قتيل رقم هو رقم
نهائي لا بل اي الرقم اكبر من ذلك بكثير
اذا اضعناه للتحليل الميداني سنجد الارقام
يمكن ان تضرب بعشره او ما او اقل من ذلك
اذا ذهبنا باتجاه تصريحات لصح لصحفيين
داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي تحدثوا عن ما يقال
11000 جريح واكثر من 1200 قتيل اذا ذهبنا
الى تصريحات المستشفيات تم الافصاح عن 650
حاله
بتر في الاطراف اذا الارقام كبيره واتوقع
ما تم الافصاح عنه هو اعلان اولي مبدئي
ولكن سيتلوه اعلانات لكن سياخذ اطار زمني
واسع وهذا ما كانت تؤكده كتائب القسام عبر
الفيديوهات التي تنشرها وكانت تستهدف بشكل
كبير الاليات العسكريه ومنها الميركافا
فنحن شيئا فشيئا تتضح الصوره تقترب اكثر
مما يقوله ما تقوله كتائب القسام لكن
ننتظر النتائج النهائيه المعلنه من الجانب
الاسرائيل بالنسبه للمركبه اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث عنها بشكل اوضح الان الميركافا مرت
في مراحل تطوير ميركافا واحد اثلاث عه
ميركافا واحد واثنين هي صممت للحرب في
المناطق الجبليه وفي المناطق المفتوحه وضد
الجيوش النظاميه ثلاثه صنفت للقتال في
المناطق المبنيه اربعه تم التحسين على
ميركافا ثلاث لكن التحسين الجوهري تمثل
باضافه في الفراغ الداخلي للدبابه اي حيز
يتسع لسته افراد جنود لان هي صممت للقتال
في المناطق المبنيه وبالتالي قد لا تتوفر
عربات ناقله للجنود مع في مع الدبابه
فيكون هناك جنود لتامين الحمايه الموضعيه
لها هذا اذا كانت هذه الدبابات محمله بهذه
الاعداد فيصبح الرقم 10 وبالتالي عند
استهداف دبابه وتفجيرها بالكامل كما
شاهدنا يكون الرقم الذي تم قتله هو 10
وليس اربعه افراد وبالتالي هذا يعدل من
المتوسط الحسابي ويرفع سقف الاعداد
النهائيه لخساره جيش الاحتلال بالحديث عن
هذه المعدات العسكريه نتحدث عن احتمال
ماليه عوده العمليات العسكريه اذا ما
توقفت الهدنه لاي سبب من الاسباب او اذا
استمرت الهدنه كما هو معلن عنه الان بان
هناك محاولات لتمديد قد تصل الى ايام
عديده الجيش الاسرائيلي هل هو قادر من
حيث ذهنيا وحتى عسكريا
ومعدات جاهزه هل يمكن ان يستمر من حيث
القدره القتاليه نعم لديه مخزون قتالي من
حيث المعدات من حيث الافراد من حيث
الذخيره الجسر الجوي الامريكي نعم يستطيع
لكن السؤال هل
المعطيات العامه تعزز ذلك التوجه تصريحات
القاده لا يزالوا يتحدثوا عن القضاء على
حماس وما بعد حماس السؤال المطروح هل هل
امريكا ستستمر بتقديم هذا الدعم والضوء
الاخضر اولا الامريكيين بدا سقف الدعم على
الاقل السياسي يتراجع كان هناك محاولات
ضغط من الجانب الامريكي بالعدم مهاجمه
قطاع غزه بالكامل والاكتفاء بالنار
والمناوره الان الموقف الامريكي الداخلي
بدا ضاغطا وبالتالي الحزب الام الديمقراط
الامريكي يجب ان ينقذ نفسه وليس انقاذ
نتنياهو هذه ورقه ضغط رئيسيه الامر الاخر
في البعد المجتمعي الاسرائيلي بعد
ان عوده الكثير من
المحتجزين قد يحفز على خ وفشل الجيش في
انقاذ سراح اي شخص الان قد يجد المسار
السلمي هو الافضل فاتوره التكاليف اذا
تكشفت اصابات جديده وقتلى جدد كلها عوامل
مانعه وبالتالي قد يكون هناك فرصه لازال
هناك فرصه جيده للحديث عن افاق سلميه
مستقبليه شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فائز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي على
كل هذه الايضاحات شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على
هذه المتابعه عوده الى الزملاء في غرفه
الاخبار